Jennifer Aniston you know we joke about
this thing but you did actually break
the internet broke it I guess I
genuinely did yes so it's not
intentionally yeah but do you know
Instagram Julie yes yeah Jennifer joined
Instagram and broke it I liked it mind
explaining that because you're asking
the wrong person
okay I think what happened was too many
people at once
I think it just got clogged I don't
really do somebody up grease yeah well
you got to a million followers faster
than anyone in history that's what you
did that's what yeah and because so
people couldn't I didn't like or follow
things because everyone was just
following you at the same time I think I
don't know no but you started big you
start your very first post of course at
friends reunion there you all are
was that like an old picture you've been
saving kind of I'm gonna break Instagram
[Laughter]
that's a recent picture because I mean
you guys whenever any of you were here
because I can toss them into a friends
reunion but this is you Fanning the
flames no this is just we'd love to get
together whenever we can cuz David lives
in New York and Matt's working ever I
mean the girls are we're very good about
keeping up with our yeah yeah I'm
together but so when that happens we
just have so much fun
[Music]
you